okay welcome to the I think the four now
final video of the default series I hope
to have covered really other other major
openings yeah this is sort of the odds
and ends let's start with the budapest
budapest gambit of course yeah what
should take of course and now black has
a choice on the pure budapest would be
that you form of course but there's also
the some good weird line Knight e4 yeah
maybe just start with 94 I never really
understood the point of this but it's
it's useful to know what's maybe the the
best line and it's a move that you
probably won't find for yourself if you
never have seen it the best move is
actually a three here and the point is
that a black is not able to to give this
check here simply which often is a
helpful move here I think now black
really doesn't have a satisfactory
continuation for instance let's say
knight c6 Knight f3 and now black
usually goes for d6 hoping that white
would take here on d6 which is possible
but maybe not not the best move it has
got some tricks IAM just for instance
let's say you would take and then just
continue development then black has got
cheap tricks like this going and you you
actually have lost your queen and so
it's it has got some points yeah but
what you need to know is
in this position the move from Quincy to
which is really fine for white the point
being that the normal move Bishop f5 is
not working simply because of 93
if black then goes for Knight g3 you
have the strong move before last night
h1 it takes f5 is basically a winning
position for white the knight on each
one will never get out and you then have
two pieces for the rook and next to pawn
and better center and so on it's it's
it's just over with with good play um
black therefore needs to play d5 here in
order to to just to save the piece of
doesn't have much much else then you can
play simple chess III and just develop
this situation in the center is just
it's just bad for black what can you say
um for instance um just an example line
if he develops now here you can play
something like this and the knight is
yeah it's lost all black needs to try
something along Queen 85 before captures
captures the rook at Queen even if this
is also basically just over two pieces
for a rook completely silly Queen on a1
and also terms of threat cm so um if
really someone comes up with 94 I think
what you need to remember is a3 and just
this trickier with with Bishop f5 Knight
c3 as I think most other things you can
just handle at the board Black has
alternatives like d6 then also Queen c2
as a problem
as moves like this don't really draw
don't really help you just develop not
f3 and before important this just keep
on developing and not try to grab a
couple of pawns or something try to get
your own development going black has
moved lots of times with a knight and
has managed to lose a pawn in the
process so it's no use to to grab even
more pawns and and weaken the position
or something just keep on developing
also black might try the tricky move
from b6 on which we also should just
develop with 93 this tempting move
actually could be it could be a problem
as this really strange line um traps the
Queen so this is a neat little trap you
really cannot get the Queen out now 95
or so it's just a problem or almost like
a 5 rook a 7 or something so important
not to fall for Queen e5
um so Queen f3 there should be seven for
instance just develop here you can of
course take this temple here and then
develop it it just hard to believe that
leg should have compensation for on here
so just remember to play a3 and play
sensible moves afterwards and you should
be fine
of course this is really a rare line and
I basically never got this I think even
in blitz or something it's really rare
but okay NAT G force played much more
often and Hyrum there's more than one
good line for white but I like a side
line here actually that I played with
much success in mostly in blitz and
rapid and it's got the advantage that
you don't need to learn any theory and
it's
it's just just fine and this is a move
III quite simple so black captures you
just return the pawn and then play
Knight h3 mmm which might look a bit
weird at first sight but the idea um is
shown afterwards that's just look at the
main moves like mostly gives a check
here now you should to the exchange t69
f4 this the idea white wants to get the
knight to have form and set up a
position which looks something like this
here and this is just a slight advantage
was the Budapest I think you cannot
expect you to get a big overwhelming
advantage this is also not the case and
the main lines but white is just all the
time somewhat better it's got better
central control and especially the
squared d5 is a problem very often white
gets a piece on d5 of course a knight
most often and black almost never can
afford to play c76 and then the d6 pawn
would be awfully weak this is just a
nice position you can grab more space in
the center maybe later for instance just
place a knight here and then if four and
four maybe or you can also play on the
Queen side it's very easy for y2 to get
something going here and Blanc doesn't
have any any significant plants or
especially you cannot move any pawns
this is just the problem with this
position c6
as mentioned weakens d6 you can play b6
but this makes playing c6 later even
more unlikely can I move the F pawn or
something it's just somewhat passive so
you can be I think very satisfied with
this kind of position and wide setup is
almost always
same sometimes black also plays
something like this d6 neither for again
g6 and you just develop as mentioned and
get a somewhat better position it's it's
not a huge advantage but it's just a
position where white can can press for
more without any risks black doesn't
have any active plans and you can just
choose if you want to play in the center
with e4 Bishop e3 or maybe play b3 maybe
not immediately but go for b3 Bishop b2
95 what can what can make some some
steady progress here and this is
difficult for black so I think this is a
really good sideline of course if you
want to invest some time you can also
study main lines like Bishop f4 or
Knight f3 they're all pretty good and
lead to some slight advantage but I
always like this idea as you don't need
to know any specific theory and you can
still get some slight advantage um yeah
this was the Budapest
what else can black play there's
actually a tricky move which I almost
forgot to mention this is here that's
six the Black Knights tango or just the
tango variation this is really a rather
respectable opening it looks a bit weird
at first sight but it's interesting yeah
I'd like to recommend also two lines
here the main line maybe the main line
is also a good line let me just show you
that f3 e6 it's mostly played and then
important move a3 of course white has
got other options like 93 for instance
it's also fine but after Bishop before
we have got some strange kind of
nimzo-indian where this Knights are
played
9 f3 and 96 and it doesn't really match
the repertoire choices both cinnamons OS
there are main plan is to go for F 3 and
E 4 so I didn't want to play NIMS over
the night here it's it's ok if you if
you like this position you can go for it
um a3 of course the main move to prevent
Bishop before and then black um mostly
switches to some kind of Kings Indian
setup with d6 and g6 before Bishop g7
and down now
I think the most promising is h3
councils Bishop g5 for instance h6
Bishop e3 rookie aides and Bishop d3
this should be somewhat better for white
it's not a great advantage but black
most likely will set up some sort of
Kings Indian formation with e5 it's it's
it's it's okay to play for white you
just maybe need to look at a couple of
more games and then you're ready to go
for this it's a very rare line so I
think this h3 Bishop g5 is a good answer
okay another idea that white could try
here is actually to really play Knight
c3 it isn't played that often but I'm
not sure why I'm maybe it white players
prefer to have somewhat simpler on play
with Knight f3 but here there are
interesting ideas let's say 5-5597 and
now the very sharp and concrete moves h4
the idea is that black is yeah somewhat
stuck here on the kingside he'd like to
play 96 but all night the g6 of course
then you get kicked with h5 this was the
idea of h4
so by far the main move here
somewhat strange looking at e2 g8 in
order to to really develop the bishop
and this white should address with a
three you know it's it looks a bit silly
here this is this hall this all the sold
secret of moved was h4 and a three but
it also have the concrete purpose now
black most often plays something like a
five to make sure that you get some
space he on the queenside and then I
found some games with III Bishop c5 and
then the really aggressive move G form
this kind of line is interesting because
white grabs a lot lot of space here on
the kingside and also in the center and
it's not so easy to see where black
might get some counter play I very much
prefer white in this position at its but
it's it's a bit unconventional you
should just pick one line here against
the tango this is really sharp
suggestion or go with the with a three
set up as I mentioned it's just good to
to look at something because if you see
this for the first time you might get
tempted into other tries that are really
not so great for instance just to have a
look if you for instance try to try to
win lots of time here you might get into
early trouble for instance this move has
been tried with the idea that this picks
up a night before is six and this whole
setup is somewhat somewhat problematic
for white because black is really quick
in developing a for instance let's say
93 Bishop before and now you need to
take care about this pawn here and that
same
this kind of this kind of line and black
has already got three pieces out will
Castle and as already trying to open up
the center it's it's really dangerous
for white its kind of line I think this
wasn't even the best way to play it with
black so make sure not to get tempted
into into refuting this who tried to
refute this with moves like t5 just pick
one of the lines that I mentioned on or
another one for instance this one of
course oops
I'll make this one 93 Bishop before this
is also fine that Queen c2 and so on
just pick one line and play this and not
try to refute this this rather rare
setup but it's it's just got some bite I
played this myself couple of times
blackened it's um it's better than it
looks okay we're almost through I think
one neat that one move I need to mention
is the d6 here 93 and now of course G
six which would suppose to regular
King's Indian but black might also try
other things for instance night BD 7 or
E 5 and both these moves yeah somewhat
tricky because if you play one of the
lines that I recommend were the Kings
Indian the lines I'm I mentioned all or
all involve not to plane early 93 but
against these setups 9b d7 or also e5
its yeah pretty much the fact that white
should play Knight f3 and let's say
Knight f3 u v e4 and if black now go
into a Kings Indian setup which she can
with g6 you get a regular Kings Indian
with the knight on f3 which is a
completely different variation of course
black has got the night on d7 so you
don't need to learn all the lines it's
just one line the line with 9b d7 but
it's still something you need to look at
I can recommend as good boost here
Bishop b3
or Quincy - there are others but these I
think may be the most challenging for
for black this was move order with 9b d7
but it can also happen why are this this
move water d5 Knight f3 Knight B to d7
and e4 and you get to get the same kind
of line after g6 so this is one one way
to go about this the other idea would be
to play something else lucky for you 5
and then if you maybe play this image
which was one recommendation you could
also play just similar to the damage
which is also fine
for instance a setup like this is very
similar to the same issue
black black here hasn't played g6 Bishop
g7 but plays the bishop here um he could
maybe try in this position to play h6 to
exchange the bishop and then maybe g3 to
have f4 again this idea so this is an
idea for people who play the damage to
setup similar as in this line after E 5
immediately it is a bit more tricky to
get into this but you could also instead
of Knight f3 which is the main move play
d5 here and then continue with a 4 + f3
which would be just a transposition the
other idea here if
if you decide for for the ninetieth
reset of course is that black of course
doesn't need to play g6 you can also
play Bishop e7 the old Indian after this
I think this Linus is maybe the the best
one with the main continuation being a
65 c5 c 5b 5 92 96 and a4 which is
slightly better for white yeah you need
to make a choice here of course this is
really a rare rare move on up it is
played really it's not not played often
I can't remember that I really got this
I think and I got it in one tournament
game 20 years or something but so it's
it's not not advisable to spend a huge
huge amount of time here but it's it's
useful to have seen it once and to
decide what kind of setup you you might
try there are also some some side lines
here for instance after e5 Knight f3
black might also try a 4 here which is
possible after that white can try Bishop
Knight g5 492 if you for instance play
the French it's just interesting to play
92 and go for some sort of reverse
trench where black has played to
somewhat strange moves Bishop f5 or we
should f4 if you think of it with
reversed colors and entity 6 or d3 from
White's point of view yeah it's um it's
it's real line this kind of lines I
think are really a bit underestimated by
theory they're not that bad
you cannot refute them and white players
usually don't don't know anything any
detailed variations here and and it
makes sense not to know that much as it
is never played so just pick pick one
line decide if you want to go for a
night f3 write a three set up okay okay
this is a bit of work as you should
acquaint yourself a bit with the Kings
Indian line really or decide to play for
instance this one or in the night be g7
move order to to go for the same here
for instance and this this order so it's
I think it's usually this kind of lines
are somewhat better for white but is
useful to yeah to have some subway idea
how you how you should play yeah I think
that's it I think I've handled all the
moves that that somehow are respectable
after after 1.d4 yeah thanks for
watching and if I have forgotten some
some really important line please
mention it in the comments and I do
further videos to to complete this
series yeah also make sure to to
subscribe to the channel if you'd like
to get informed about for the uploads
it's free and very useful to keep up to
date yeah thanks and until the next
video